foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I gotta switch and fix these
I can't stand it I will have it
[Music]
all right
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
all right we live we live
I I uh so first off guys we do have a
new overlaying stuff it will be here
next week
uh the stuff takes time man stuff takes
time it's pretty much the exact same
thing you're seeing now it's just we did
change things around
so what's going on King man uh first off
did did you did you watch the voyagers
you know let's start with the homework
first okay it's not called voyages
whatever whatever it's called cool
voyers right and okay
um first I was sick ever since uh
Thanksgiving YouTube
um you were completely under the level I
think he was under the weather before
yeah Thanksgiving right I still actually
last Tuesday I was already coughing from
uh okay whatever I had
so you you got it you got it then I woke
up uh that Friday morning because I was
supposed to do boom show breakfast boom
and I was completely dead I was wasted
right
um and I thought it was the Gin
so Thanksgiving not at all I was sick
sick so
I didn't get a chance to watch Attack on
Titan
and I said I'm gonna watch this movie
and then and I go to Amazon Prime
I'm like yo
what the hell is attic talking about
because I put up the Voyages I had a
movie from like three years ago that I
had this other movie so I'm like yo I
think it's this movie right here
and then
you know my girl's like yo don't watch
it and you watch the Royal film and
you're getting there talking about the
Rogue film yeah
I was like yo yo let me let me send it
to him and and I told you take a
screenshot and send it to me and you
took a screenshot you sent it to me and
I was like that's not even that's not
even voyages that's Voyage so I was like
okay
uh so you want me to set it up since
being that you saw it first
I I can I can start off all right so
um I'm gonna give y'all the basic
premise of the movie The basic premise
of the movie is a couple a young couple
move into a new Loft in France together
and
um
it's the new experience no children
fresh out of school
um
well one been out of school for a minute
and they had taken different paths to
get to where he was at and
as anyone knows what the word Voya means
that is to basically be concealed in uh
view other people doing things right so
and that's a popular thing in France
how that sits with me
this this movie touched a lot of
insecurities
right and then and that's it right there
so I love the actor that played in
Pokemon
I love the fact that he's probably like
the new Young uh black face in in in
Disney and and movies and stuff like
that and he was in uh Jurassic Park the
last one
um so and he was in like uh Transformers
or something something like that
whatever
um but I really like his stuff
this one
I think it was a little bit of a
covenant age of him so I started to
watch the film and like I said it
touched a lot of insecurities in me one
as a male
uh you know a man
relationship wise
to
as an individual as you know that stops
snitching stuff I'm really heavy on that
but also money a business right so this
thing
it was like uh
it was like torture watching it
to be honest with you right so from the
onset of the film
I don't like the girlfriend I don't like
her at all right so she comes in and
she's Super Hyper to be here and he's
like you know he's like a laid back
chill dude I'm a laid-back chill dude
she's too hyper and her her name is
Peppa so she's like pepped up she's like
she's like she's ready to go all the
time and
like the first night they get there
they're sitting down and eating Chinese
food and she's like hey babe uh Let's
Make a Deal
no kids for the first four years
that's it that's a
that's a crazy way to start a movie
first off like yeah it's just like what
I liked about it um hold up remember
that movie we watched like voyagers
no voyers voyers the the one about the
the couple that moved into the apartment
and they were like stalking the
neighbors
okay she she has short-term memory it's
fine but so so what what I liked about
it is just I like movies that you think
you understand what's going on
but you don't I didn't understand
anything about this film not a damn
thing every time it took a Different
Twist I was going twisting in the wind
with it and I guess because I was so
emotionally heavily invested in hating
the girlfriend right so
he's like
through through the College Years
because she was a shut-in she studied
she went to school this is gonna be her
life this is going to be what she's
supposed to do she's a uh
ophthalmologist or something like that
uh working with the eyes right
and oh assistant she's moving up the
food chain and she just got out of
college and she tells her
Whatchamacallit she tells she tells a
man
I want to live crazy for four years
he already did drugs and all that
because he was in the bed
so this dude wants to chill out right so
he's here with this this girl who's
ready to jump off and do everything
and not that I'm I'm sitting there
uncomfortable with this film addict and
I'm like what does addict have me
watching and then they see the people
across the way yeah so so pretty much
this this movie's about a couple peeping
Tom like and they take this to the next
level like we're not talking about just
looking at him a couple times we're
talking full-blown stalking the
neighbors across the street because like
they're in like a giant Penthouse like
they're rich rich like it's not a
penthouse okay they're not rich rich
they they're they're well to do at it
like Okay so
I gotta explain to attic right because
in New York Aloft downtown it costs some
bucks it's just like you renting a house
or getting a house so you say you pay
like three grand a month right you're
paying like three grand a month and
that's like 1500 per person right
but you gotta know
in New York that's kind of normal
right so they're in France probably a
little bit different
but everywhere they're at is lost
so financially they're well to do you're
right on that part you're right on that
part financially they're well to do but
they're still young well go ahead Eric
sorry yeah so you know we
I don't think we should go too much into
the spoiler territory but I do recommend
you guys like it this this movie you
know first off King what what you know
from watching it
what would you give this some popcorn
ratings uh for for our audience that
they want to watch uh The Voice the
voyeurs on on Amazon it's an Amazon
original Amazon Prime yeah it's an
Amazon original so you can only watch it
on that website what would you give it
in popcorn
foreign
don't watch it with your kids
don't have kids around this is a an
erotica
it's heavily
to do with uh sexual innuendos sexual
overtness
uh heavily mature uh situations
um very deep thought content
um question how did you how'd the wife
feel about it she watch it with you she
watched it how'd she feel about it she
like it
she she knew about it because she saw it
in the trailers she saw her before
she she figured it out before I did oh
so she figured the twist out
yeah I didn't figure it out until it
happened I'm not gonna lie I did I
didn't figure out the final twist
because yeah because there's like four
twists in the in the movies yeah the
final twist I finally got it by a visual
cue they kept showing throughout the
film
because I kept saying what the hell has
that got to do with anything and I was
really pissed off with why they keep
showing this thing
and at the end you'll realize why they
show that thing but
again
I went back and forth I was going to
give it a two star I mean a two two
popcorn
but then I S I had to reevaluate and I
had to sleep on it
and I said for the level of Ingenuity
that they did it's a well-paced movie it
is very well paced
very well thought out
um and conceptualize and visualization
sound design uh and you got to really
think this movie is done in only a
couple of settings probably like four
four different
um uh settings right their house uh the
the people's house her job and uh in
another place or two place two more
places
very very short on settings
but very well acted so I gotta give it a
three three popcorn just for that
um I had to take off one popcorn because
I can't stand the girl and I knew she
was gonna do exactly what she did and
get to where she was so I actually used
I got to give it so you give it a three
I mean yeah do the three popcorn
I'm giving it a four
uh I feel like they intentionally made
you hate that chick because they wanted
you to hate her more for the stuff she
does in the movie like towards like the
middle of the movie when she starts
going like Beyond like like you think
too much yeah she so I think that was
the intention from the start now I don't
like the Redemption she got I felt like
she shouldn't have got nothing it should
have ended you you know what I'm saying
like yeah uh but but I do think this is
a good it's a good watch like this is
like one of those things where I I
honestly feel like you guys should uh
you guys should go check out man I I
think you guys would like it uh you know
we're not gonna really go too much into
it now I think the only time that we'll
ever like do real big spoilers is when
we do a spoiler movie like a Marvel
movie I think we're gonna do one with
the Avatar next next month uh you know
there we we I think
the way we're going to try to maneuver
this because like my
the way I would like to for these to go
King is like we just watch it we'll make
it recommending these stuff to each
other and where and we get our audience
to go watch it too uh so yeah uh the
voyeurs I think definitely you know
something you guys should go watch I
think you guys are gonna enjoy it and
you know if if you guys watch it you
know tag us on Twitter man tell us how
you liked it tag us on Twitter tell us
how you like it I need to hear a
Dragonheart yobi's thought on it because
you know I saw him inside the chat I saw
him I think I am sales is in there too I
definitely watch that sales
um that
I'm telling you is a couple of twists in
there is one twist in there that I I was
going to throw the TV remote I was so
pissed off with that twist
um because it it really made me really
upset so I I should have gave it uh
probably you know full popcorn but I
can't stand them so much man yeah I can
understand what why someone would give
it a three popcorn but I will say it's
better than that nonsense you had me
watch last week like you know what and
I'm and I'm you're right
what I will say is that the stuff you
had me watch last week isn't a bad movie
I just felt like there were things they
did that could have fixed it and you
know little things and this thing this
movie
didn't have anything that you needed to
fix
this movie was really a complete movie
it was it was probably a great read and
I gotta find out if there's a book about
it uh the voyers and and check the the
re what the what did Dragonheart say he
said I'm watching this tonight and I
will get back to you this sounds very
intriguing yeah that's why you know last
because last week when we went into huge
detail on the uh the movie I was just
sitting there was like you know because
we broke it down so much we can't like
let people experience it so you know
we'll do better on that uh so what what
I want to do with this is I do feel like
we're gonna have to have it about half
the show where we're talking about you
know
stuff that's going on kind of like an
IOP we talk about the news and gaming
so I did notice that they're they're
making first off we're going to talk
about Thor taking a break and uh what's
his name Chris Chris Hemsworth
apparently he's uh thinking about taking
a break uh there's been some like
takeovers going on at Marvel 2 or Disney
in general or Disney so that's
interesting when we want to talk briefly
talk about that uh but you know what I
saw that I want to talk about they're
making a 90s show a 90d show you know
the 70s Show the 90s show yeah they're
making a 90s show that'll be good and
the trailer
has red I don't know if you've ever seen
the 70s Show it's got two older people
uh it's in Wisconsin and it's got the I
used to watch the 70s Show red looks
identical that he looked back then
wait they think they're not gross
they're not aging
and apparently uh it's Eric's uh it's
Eric's granddaughter that is is living
with them and so it I like stuff like do
like that because it's like you know I'm
curious if they're gonna go back to the
old characters in any way you know uh so
I'm very interested it comes out January
like the 18th so and I'm about to go pay
for the new Rick and Morty I think the
new Rick and Morty already hit so I got
to get myself over there to see that
um also I didn't even check this week to
see what came out new
uh on um on Netflix so I'm gonna go
through the you know the the top 10 on
that apparently then on um they're about
to go back to launch like a Witcher
prequel I don't know if you heard about
that like it's a what's your prequel did
you see uh the Black Panther the first
black panther they're gonna make a
series out of the first black panther no
I didn't oh my God I don't I don't know
too much about like comic books and
stuff was that uh Charles like Dad or
was there one above okay
um it's cool it's a Disney plus movie
yes it's going to be a Disney Plus show
so you know definitely for a fact that
we're going to cover that let me find it
it's in um one of my chats that I'm in
I'm just like so you know
I do think we will we'll break a little
bit um
yeah bashanga the first black panther oh
that's gonna be interesting uh one thing
I I want to talk about
oh he looks crazy
yeah yo that that looks more
intimidating the actual black panther
like he said one thing I want to talk
about a little bit is
I want to talk about what you consider
the top three actors in in history or
like in history yeah and that like
that's let's say that's
yeah let's say yeah your top three
actors top three actors I mean for me
for me
um
wow
James Earl Jones
okay hold up I'm gonna have to Google
these people because some of them I
don't know well James Earl Jones is
Darth Vader's voice
he just didn't use his face so when he
took the mask off me as a kid was like
oh hell no
[Laughter]
I said oh man I was I was I was crazy
mad because I was like yeah you know a
Darth Vader black and he made a little
white baby
um it ain't true so they had the other
guy
um but he had James or Jones voice I I
love James L Jones
oh
I gotta go with Al Pacino
Al Pacino
Al Pacino
started
a revolution
in rebellious
entrepreneurship by any means necessary
from where I grew up
if he wasn't trying to be Scarface she
wasn't trying to live right so Al Pacino
inadvertently
uh
yeah Al Pacino
inadvertently
so so much
and so much good at the same time when I
look at like actors I look at like a
variety of acting like there's actors
that do stuff really good and I feel
like there's actors that do everything
good uh I would actually consider like
one of the best actors is
um
is Johnny Depp because like
that dude could put himself in a variety
of roles it didn't matter like like for
the most part he can literally jump in
any row he pretty I've seen him in in
action one suspense he was in stuff like
the secret window he he's done uh action
adventure Like Pirates of the Caribbean
like I I think that
I think Dwayne Johnson's a good actor
but there's only certain things he can
do well he can do the same face that's
what I meant like there's only certain
things he can do he could never like you
said look at someone like um
what's uh uh man what is him the oh
what's that actor called oh
um I'm gonna give you my top three
and then you know
um
Denzel Washington he's one of them too
he can play he's out of my top three he
could play no I'm talking about people
that just play really good he he he can
play really good roles if you give it to
him
he's not easy to work with either no
he's not because every perfectionist has
a problem
but I'm I'm gonna go with Robert De Niro
to round out my three
Taxi
driver
is one of my quintessential films
if if you've never seen taxi driver I
urge everybody to get up go out and go
check it out you know well you know get
up go right to your living room and hit
your PlayStation or your Xbox yeah right
right I actually that's the dude from
the casino stuff right yes he he and
what's funny is like
they they kind of low-key do him dirty
where it's like anything Italian we got
Robin in there we got to get him in
there uh obviously he does that really
well you don't really see him in
anything that's not like that that mob
style type of movie obviously he's been
in stuff like uh Meet the Fockers and
stuff but uh I personally feel like yeah
he he's just he's a good well-rounded
actor uh you know me have you ever seen
Heat
I feel like I have I feel like that's
what Robert De Niro and Al Pacino
um what's a you know actually how do you
feel about Brad Pitt you think he's a
good actor I love Brad Pitt I thought
Angelina Jolie sucked the soul out of
him pause
um I I think you know why you know I was
so mad because
I thought Troy
for a very long time because I was
heavily into Roman film Rome and stuff
like that and for a long period of time
I thought Troy
was a stand-alone I mean because I I
I've watched all of them I watched
Spartacus I watched all those films
and I thought Troy stood alone and I
said this is it this is his joint this
is his jumping off point this is him
he's
then Along Comes the succubus
and after they did uh Mr and Mrs Smith
cut his uh cut his wings he can do uh
movies uh you don't really see him in
too many movies anymore dude you know
what you know I like and I know he's
like a very one-dimensional actor I like
the dude who played Lex Luthor in Batman
versus Superman like I didn't like him
in that role but I I liked him and and
social me uh social network the movie
about Facebook being made you talking
about the other dude is uh Robin
Zuckerberg yeah yeah he he just I like
that the energy he gives out in those
times like when he plays that type of
role like he's definitely a
one-dimensional actor you don't really
see him in too many uh uh you know
variety different stuff uh but it's it's
interesting you know let me get what's
your top three you got mine what's yours
I would have to say
I don't I used to be a huge fan of um
Edward Norton but I feel like he kind of
went downhill but I would have to say
Denzel Washington's one of my top three
I don't know if I can if I can give you
the top three like an order but I would
have to say it doesn't matter yeah
Denzel Washington's one of them because
I don't
I don't know too many movies that's a
bad movie with him in it you know maybe
maybe it's because he's so selective on
what he picks you know he uh but I would
actually say that you know he he plays a
really really good roles
um
Leonardo DiCaprio I think I think
Leonardo DiCaprio see if you just told
me in my top five
Leonardo DiCaprio is in my top five
you know and and very three-dimensional
actor can do almost anything you could
throw him in and I honestly think that
the Departed is one of the best movies
that's ever been made like the word The
Departed yeah but my mine was Wolf of
Wall Street Buffalo Wild Street man I
love that movie man that that solidified
him and
when he he gets home and he thought he
drove home without wrecking in anything
and the cops show up and he hit
everything
yeah I I really like that um I would
actually Leonardo DiCaprio is my top
three one of myself three you know what
let's see bullet train
Bullet Train That's Brad Pitt's movie
that uh it it should be on find out
where it's where it's at if it's if it's
on something or whatever we just pay for
it and get reimbursed or whatever but um
oh I see it um
let me I'll look that up in one second
let me throw another one out to you man
how you feel about uh uh Marky Mark
what's Mark what about no you don't like
him I don't know man I'm a little no no
Mark Wahlberg is a smart actor you know
he made the transition but is he diverse
no he's as diverse as uh uh Sylvester
Stallone and and if you want to give me
Sylvester Stallone I'll take some don't
give me Sylvester still on light I'll
take Sylvester Stallone heavy any day
Jonathan Mages what do you think about
him
that's the dude that's playing King the
Conqueror did you see the Loki Series
yeah on Disney plus I'd have to I don't
think
uh what's his name look uh Jonathan
major C Lovecraft country
Jonathan that guy's crazy yeah I I know
I've seen him in movies before but
sometimes like you don't realize who
these like I didn't know that Daryl from
The Walking Dead was in Blade 2 for
years oh yeah yeah so
but he didn't blow up until he got over
to The Walking Dead
yeah which you know that that's
debatable if he's a good actor or not I
cannot wait to see Creed 3 just because
of Jonathan major
yeah I see him he's been in a couple
pretty decent movies yeah that that boy
he's out of control yeah so okay
um bullet train
is that what you you your thing is this
week yeah we'll train bullet train all
right something we both didn't see but
something that's very current and
something that has an actor in it that
we both really you know think very
highly of that didn't get enough shine
to be honest with you full of train all
right so shout out to my wife for
texting me because I was like yo we need
a movie we need a movie now so yeah so
all right so thank you let's get on to
the news man uh first off
you know it's gonna take us a little bit
of getting used to you know what's funny
I was
about yesterday I was looking like where
do I even look up TV and movie moves
like
I don't I'm so used to the gaming stuff
like I follow gaming YouTubers and you
know podcasts it's a YouTube I don't
look up anything when it comes to to
movies I had a I kind of call my friend
Tyler up I'm like yo
where do I look for news man like what's
going on in the news one that's how I
found out about the 90s show because I
started clicking these websites this
gives you like updates and stuff on
stuff and I'm like you know clearly I'm
gonna have to do a little research
before these shows because uh you know
we we gotta gotta keep up with stuff
going on you know uh first off let's
talk about the mar the Disney takeover
stuff inform me on what's going on that
was okay so the old CEO
took over the job and they did it like a
coup
in like in the middle of the night he
found out on Twitter
that he got fired and the old CEO was
back in the position
so they got rid of the Oco
I mean okay so the new CEO was there and
they got rid of the old CEO they brought
him back
and got rid of the new one and and
reinstated him back into the position
um it's just
he needs to get the money back up
because uh profitability is down at uh
Disney plus which is weird but HBO and
Max you know that's that's done right oh
so that's done yeah that's done this
year it's done initiating gonna do
something else and fix it
um you know James Gunn uh the dude that
did Guardians of the Galaxy
is what you doing the dude that did
Guardians of the Galaxy one two and
three uh is now the head of Warner
Brothers
oh that's weird I I don't know he's
going to give them good directions
I didn't really like Guardian of the
Galaxy 2 in three like I thought two was
okay uh I actually really I enjoyed the
first one though I will say I enjoyed
the first one
you didn't like the second one that's
the one with his dad right
yeah that one made me cry
instead of
I have to I have to get back to you on
that man I think it's one of those
things see I got daddy issues though you
don't so he goes he's your pops but he
ain't your daddy
and he gave him he he saved his life
and gave his life for his
it's yo I'm sorry man I mean that is
he chose to support this kid they
abducted the wrong kid
he chose
to support the kid you know
and then it's and it was a funny story
for me it's like one of those stories
where they make someone be real hard at
the beginning and then throw out a
couple movies they start softing him up
maybe it's because I saw that as a
cop-out like that's just the easy thing
to do you know to get rid of his
character by him sacrificing himself
because it's not like I haven't seen
that in a thousand different things
I'm at the end his team came back for
his Redemption he got redemption in his
death yeah okay you just showed up for
him
and they gave him more ravages because
yeah I'll give you that because they
said that he he would never have a
referred to send off yup and they was
dead it was
like and his boy his boy the crazy dude
oh and they it's I'm such a huge nerd
that the original dudes we got Sylvester
Stallone was with those are the original
Guardians her Galaxy from the comic
books if anybody who wants to go back
and look at it that was another good
series The Expendables I like those
movies yeah yeah it was it was fun so so
now that so this dude came back what
what's what's going on now like prices
are going to be raised over Disney
do you think that that's gonna change
anything drastically or do you think for
them anyway
well what do you mean money-wise like
I'm kind of they're gonna they're gonna
raise the subscription fee they're gonna
diversify on how they roll it out
they're gonna do a little bit more how
do they not make programming
they're making billions off almost every
movie they do at least but you also
understand the production that goes into
it the the
cost of fees and paying that's why when
you watch a Disney film or a Marvel
movie at the end the credits is like 10
minutes long
all those people but I mean
they said that I think they spent 400
million on
um I think that it was end game and they
made like 2 billion
so to me it's just like
and like they got to be wasting mad
money like besides there's a lot of
shows in production though yeah you
don't think Disney plus pays for that
eventually
I don't know we'll figure it I don't
they said they have like six
corporations they said they had like 69
million uh subscribers
hey chat look up look up on Google how
many subscribers when they hit the 50
million Mark they said that they were
just getting ready to break even
so excuse me
I don't know
um I I figure that they're going to
raise the cost of Disney Plus
so I encourage everybody go out right
now and extend it to as far as you can
before they raise the price on it
because if you're doing month to month
it's gonna hit you uh
and just relax and enjoy the ride
because there's a lot of shows that
should be showing up and should be
popping up right now Disney reported uh
results of the final quarter of 2022
physical year today revealing a total of
164 million Disney plus global
subscribers that's ridiculous yeah
there's no way they're not paying for
those movies those TV shows they like I
get that they cost money but 164 million
and let's be real here King
the only thing those shows really got
it's a bunch of Disney plush stuff
like their Disney catalog and the stuff
that and these these Marvel and and
these Marvel and um
and Star Wars stuff they're putting in
there they don't got much more than that
these dudes is going crazy right now for
the Mario uh trailer I haven't watched
it have you I haven't seen it either and
see I would live react it with King but
it's just like look like here here's the
thing
if I had to go to Cognito and explain to
him why we got struck well we got called
right
and why we can't do IOP anymore until
the strike is lifted it's gonna be very
very hard conversation all right
we're we're not gonna do that
um we all here know how Nintendo is
so
again
have fun watching a trailer
I'll talk about it later on Twitter and
plus we are going to redo the patreon
and the members stuff we might put stuff
like that behind the members and patreon
stuff because I know it's it's a lot
easier to maintain back then so you know
we might do something on patreon where
if you want to see uh our reactions to
certain things then we'll put that on
there because and patreon you're not
gonna snipe Us on YouTube
they can't yeah because but you see you
guys know
y'all know Microsoft doesn't care if we
you know do their trailers and stuff
like that Sony
to a large extent really doesn't really
hit people
Nintendo hits each and every last person
yeah especially I you know they're a lot
better with games now
but I don't know how they're gonna be
with that yeah and this is
probably yeah and plus we still got
stuff going on here uh uh we did make
some significant changes to the overlay
you see now uh this is pretty much like
for the next three
to four months we're going to be moving
the the show constantly like okay this
works this doesn't work uh IOP took
years before we had a good you know
format yeah
you know what's funny King people think
when it comes to podcasts all you got to
do is show up like no there's a lot that
goes into podcasts that no one sees let
me tell you something what attic does
because everybody thinks that
um I do a whole bunch
yeah I stayed up to two in the morning
last night doing shorts he does
a hell of a lot all right so um I'm
really a concept guy I can go and I can
come up with this see how the overlay
looks and I can go in I can go up with a
whole bunch of stuff everybody has a
different Talent so it's very hard to
emulate his talent he can't emulate my
talent I can't emulate his talent and
we're trying something like God's talent
and we don't emulate sovereign's Talent
right so at the end of the day we let
the weight hang on Sovereign we just hit
him up like yo we need that
um
but yeah no it's not easy guys so okay
what else what else um so we did our
best actors
and we we talked about the movie we gave
it I gave it three you gave it four yeah
um
um but we we're gonna watch bullet train
bullet train that will be but but I
still I still need those six episodes of
Attack on Titan I'm gonna watch it I was
just really sick man I was taking so
much medicine and the medicine was
really out of control so
um
but I was like laid out so
I feel you I mean I was sick too man
like the good thing is I didn't have
nothing to watch
because she watched it but now you do so
yeah oh bullet train will be good uh
yeah I'm I'm probably watch that tonight
and go right to bed because it's almost
dinner time anyway so yeah and plus I
was thinking like what we can do for
like big big shows uh is you know we
obviously when big movies come out we're
gonna have a show dedicated to just that
once we feel more comfortable talking
about things we'll incorporate that what
I do want to do is because I've had this
voyagers thing up in the middle is I
want to have that eventually just rotate
it as
as just the logo over and over again and
then one I need to use that real estate
I'll put it in there it's gonna take a
little bit of time but you know the good
thing is it's nice to talk about
something that's not gaming
I didn't feel like talking about the
video games at all especially you know
what I've been playing all week so not
gonna happen but um we could save that
for IOP too hell yeah and this week's
going to be interesting
you know I I still I got to finish the
Pokemon review I'm doing uh yeah it's
not going to be highlight uh people the
Pokemon Community King are about to come
at me they're about to come at me
they're going to look under every Rock
they're gonna look under everything they
can get until they find me because I'm
gonna obsess some people tell them put
on attic goal and try to fight yeah yeah
you know what I actually think that um
for people that like anime
yeah that my hero getting good man I
don't know people in the chat that like
that likes anime but my hero has been
hitting hard my hero my hero Academia
it's pretty much like
no I I think I know that that's the one
where they get a different power or
something like that no pretty much my
hero is 80 of the world yeah has powers
they call them quirks
and only two uh 20 don't have them so
when you have 80 of the world you have
all these Heroes coming together to make
like agencies to protect people because
there's so many people that have them
you know like one punch man yeah well I
don't like one punch man I don't know
why I don't like much so like addict now
pretty much the main character his name
is uh Deku well like uh uh and the like
they have a ranking King they have like
the top 10
Heroes and number one is this this hero
named almight and he's pretty much one
punch man like like he but but he's fast
he's built like he he's like he's huge
he's huge and you find out that
all might can give his powers to people
oh it was pretty much he passes the
torch to other people when he's done uh
so what ends up happening is Deku is
quirkless he doesn't have a quirk and he
and his whole imagine being the 20 of
the world that don't have quirks
but he but he can give him power he all
might eventually all my like pretty much
what happens is Deku doesn't have powers
in one of his classmates in the First
episodes getting attacked right and he
doesn't have a quirk
and he goes in there to save him without
a quirk
and you you have all but all my pretty
much what happens is almight was injured
they say all this in the first episode
so it's not really spoiling anything uh
almight's injured and eventually he's
gonna lose his powers he's gonna because
he can only maintain them for like 30
minutes a day at this point so he knows
he's gonna have to give it to someone
eventually but he's deciding who
and Deku when he had no quirk walks into
to someone that has powers that has one
of his classmates that all might was
like this dude
is going to run out there knowing he's
probably gonna die just to protect
someone
so he ends up giving his powers to Deku
and what's funny is
Deku is small
like a fraction of the size that all
might is so Deku can only use five
percent of his strength
because once he gives it to him he's
using five percent because the so pretty
much King when he gets all my Powers he
goes into the interest exams which is
pretty much like the the classroom thing
where everyone's deciding and the first
time he uses almight's Powers he breaks
his arm like shatters it it's going like
this because he doesn't know how to
contain the power it's way too strong
for his body and so he can only use five
percent without his arm doing this like
and no like King it's worse there's
times in the show where is it like all
his limbs are doing this because it the
only way he knows heal no no he does not
heal like there's a chick there that
kisses you and heals you it's another
chicken this chick next to him no it's
it's the nurse of the school that has
the ability when they when she kisses
you on the forehead it Hills all your
injuries
so like pretty much like if if he at the
beginning if he uses any of his powers
he's like not breaking his arm is
shattered like it's doing this like okay
so wait wait that's in what what is in
that that's in Crunchyroll yes that's in
Crunchyroll okay
but Attack on Titan's your assignment
okay
we got to get you to the good episode of
Attack on Titan then we'll work on my
hero all right all right all right so
that's pretty much the show guys uh you
know it's like I said wasn't a long show
there's not a lot going on right now
unfortunately he's not a lot of shows uh
power's over
um
you liked it right see and you saw the
new trailer for BMF too right no what is
that you didn't see the new trailer for
the new BMI I don't know what that is
wait you didn't see BMF the first series
I don't know what BMF is you don't have
to
stop abbreviating just tell me
oh no um Black Mafia Family no I didn't
see it is it's on the same thing as
power
no I didn't see that okay okay so what
was that about who's that so okay whoa
big meat
okay I watched the Tommy show
that's cool that's cool you you you
you're heavily invested into Power I get
it I'm heavily invested into power too I
gotta do I Gotta See Tommy's joint I got
to see Force
um they didn't bring back his son yet
right
yes his son has their own show it's
called No the next one because season
two there's two seasons of his okay so I
saw the second season I haven't seen the
second season okay I think I think I saw
all both the canes I love Kane's show
Kane is a good Raising Cane I gotta see
the next raising king that's the one I'm
oh I was at I had to see that one all
right so BMF
oh
no no okay those stuff is fictional
right
BMF is real okay now they're going to
give you a little bit of twist on on
some of the stuff that was going on to
meet you and and Black Mafia family's
life but this is real events based on
true facts that was uh
um detailed in the federal archives and
from uh testimonies and stuff like that
from the people and actually meech who's
in prison right now
his son is playing his role who was
doing a damn good job to be honest with
you as of playing Meech
watch BMF you're going to be
heavily addicted to that if you like
Power you're gonna like it a lot
yeah
I'll look up a trailer when I get I'm
going to look up a trailer on this Mario
game movie too I look we're gonna have
to do a spoiler cast on the Mario thing
we're just gonna have to like
um you know what we should do we should
do a Whatchamacallit like a live a live
straight to Twitter or something
something that doesn't involve the
channel
uh what we is that gonna that's in the
movies isn't it
or the oh are you talking about um I
thought you was talking about the
trailer no I was talking about doing a
spoiler cast on that when it does come
out oh the movie yes yeah yeah that's in
the movie you know we we can't
we'll figure out something to do with
that we'll figure out something to do
with that but you know I appreciate it
for coming through man
real quick yeah I will watch BMF I will
watch being back all right so you got
BMF and I got Attack on Titan yeah six
ounces episode six that's what it was up
to six episode six all right
bullet train yes we